[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
May 4th I'm J.R Wellen for the Wall
Street Journal
many workers have high expectations for
raises in 2023 but those hopes for a
fatter paycheck are likely to be met
with disappointment Wall Street Journal
reporter Ray Smith is here to discuss
plans by some employers to scale back so
Ray let's talk numbers what kind of
raises are employees expecting this year
according to a survey of thousands of
employees conducted in the fall by ADP
62 percent said they were confident that
they will get a pay raise from their
current Employers in the next 12 months
and 41 were confident they would receive
a bonus
so that's a lot of workers expecting to
get pay raises or bonuses
and 10 of those workers expect a salary
increase of over 15 percent in the next
12 months all right and so what's the
reality check what are companies
budgeting for and why are they scaling
back companies are budgeting slightly
smaller annual Merit increases in total
compensation packages for 2023 then they
projected they would when they were
surveyed in November they planned annual
Merit increases of 3.8 and 4.1 percent
on average and now that's slightly below
the 3.9 and 4.3 percent they projected
in November the labor market is cooling
so companies don't feel as much pressure
to use raises and bonuses as a retention
tool and companies are tightening belts
amid economic uncertainty
you know with reception fears and mass
layoffs of White Collar jobs the cooling
jobs Market even falling inflation and
housing prices there are a lot of
factors that are going to why companies
don't feel the pressure to Dole out
raises or bonuses as they have been
doing over the past two to three years
but at many companies over the past
several years workers have gotten used
to Hefty raises being offered by
companies how could this affect the
relationship between workers and their
employers there's long been tension
between workers and employers so this
doesn't help pay is a major gripe for
employees and we've already had tensions
over everything from work life balance
and return to office so this definitely
doesn't help especially because as we
said over the past two years workers
were accustomed to seeing these raises
and bonuses and now it's just another
thing that's being taken away from them
over the past two years it was pretty
common for companies to give out raises
during the year not just at the usual
time on the calendar when companies have
scheduled raises to go out what should
workers expect this year with regard to
those off calendar raises they should
lower their expectations basically
because companies survey by Mercer said
they were less likely to give out as
many of those off calendar raises and
bonuses throughout the year and so
that's just something that employees
will have to sort of adjust their
expectations for the fact that we're not
going to see as many sporadic or Merit
increases or bonuses given out when it's
not scheduled to be given out basically
off calendar but does the phrase it
doesn't hurt to ask apply here even in
the face of smaller salary budgets how
should workers approach their manager
about getting a salary increase if they
feel they deserve it they can make a
strong case why they deserve a raise
over the list of like concrete
accomplishments and how much they're an
asset to the company it's no guarantee
but it helps if they can also show proof
of what others with the same or similar
titles are making at their competitors
with Statistics from sites like
Glassdoor or even job postings in states
with paid transparency laws they should
also ask for more than they actually
want on the assumption that if the high
numbers rejected the company will come
back with something they could at least
be okay with and even when companies are
dealing with leaner times they still
have to maintain a staff and it's money
that can unlock the challenge of finding
and recruiting workers right yes that's
right companies will do what they can to
try to make the numbers work in order to
retain talented staff so you do have a
good point there but also Force comes to
worse employees can negotiate other
things in lieu of money like more work
from home days for instance and it's
just a question of how competitive the
market is how many workers they need to
retain in order to be successful in
business that's Wall Street Journal
reporter Ray Smith and that's your money
briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
foreign
[Music]